Hans uh welcome back to the show uh you
gave us a heart attack you probably gave
yourself a heart attack I will ask you
once again did the chess speak for
itself
today yes yes it did yes it did
yesterday it didn't but today did
finally congratulations now take us did
yesterday but not in the way that I
imagined of course now every day the
chest is speaking there was a will to
win today that I have to say impressed
me because you had the opportunity to
repeat the position not once but twice
and yet you decided to keep the game
going tell us a bit about that reaction
and that decision in that particular
moment which which two times the F the
first one which is on the board now yes
withing this was the first one Knight H5
Knight F4 King H6 potentially King to G7
you decided to go F5 I'm I'm not risking
anything here I have better piece Play
Active uh I'm not risking there's no
Point uh the second point when I didn't
that was much more tricky yes I think it
was at this point when you decided to go
Queen B6 Queen B8 and finally to go King
to H7 and allow Knight to F4 and as soon
as I played it I was uh very upset um
but you know if you want to win against
such strong players you have to uh risk
you have to you have to bite the bullet
absolutely and you did Knight to F4 by
the way was a great move by him and
after that things are getting 95 wait
wait wait wait start go back wait wait
95 Queen R what what should can I just
check what's so Rook Rook C5 B Rook ke
play Oh Knight G4 Knight G4 is the best
move in the because I just because you
know when I was thinking about position
after night night G4 I was just getting
flashbacks through yesterday yesterday
like night G4 night G5 I was getting
like some PTSD I was like I just because
I I I knew that I felt n four I just
make a draw I don't lose but I was just
like I got it I got to go I got to go I
got to go and the time is taking down
and like getting these flashbacks and
it's just so
painful and then uh speaking of
flashbacks I it was move 39 after the
move Knight to F4 and at this point you
had 5 seconds on the clock you grabb the
Knight you put it on G4 four three take
a look at this because we actually have
the footage I remember trust me I
remember take a look at this take us
through this decision
making so I I'm thinking night G4 and
then in a split second I see Rook F5
boom and then I'm like oh no oh no what
do I do where where can the night go I'm
and as and then I then and then I see
but you went back to G4 close you went
back to G4 yes oh
I and one second H I didn't realize I
didn't realize I did the triple you know
twist you know that's uh that's a triple
twist yes
okay guess there's a first for every
triple twist in your
[Laughter]
life amazing and you press your clocks
uh Hans with a a second were you aware
that that was done with one second on
your clock I was aware right after I
looked at the clock
disbelief yet gratitude for Kaa looking
down on me gratitude that you're surv
ding but at the same time you're still
losing in that position after Knight to
G6 how did you assess it did you know
that you're losing did you feel that
you're losing or you were still Haring
it's I'm down upon uh uh the the Knight
has has great potential um but of course
I hard would hope the B2 Pawn is very
weak um there's potential sacrifices
attacking on the king so uh you know he
got into time pressure and he collapsed
at the end mhm mhm beautiful uh
execution h I have to say uh guys any
questions for H after this crazy game
I'm
recovering I don't know about you Hans
but uh you you you've traumatized our
crew here and how do you feel I mean you
were that close to well defeat and now
you're tied for first quite
extraordinary honestly this this was
nothing compared to yesterday I was you
know cool chill my ual arrogant Optimist
self you know um uh I think yesterday
got the juices flowing uh This was um
this I just felt like I would play Super
I'm just playing very very well um I
think in both of these games just
there's just one moment where I'm just
uh going absolutely insane um so I just
have to be more more consistent and and
um but I think my general level is quite
good the opening and how I played I
think was very successful in this game
um and uh it's definitely very important
to be the leader with the black pieces
absolutely and H what was your
assessment after you played Queen D1 and
captured the Knight on B3 did you think
you winning there or did you see any
variation that could yeah well on my on
my walk here um someone spoiled that
Rook A5 was actually holding um but uh I
did think that I was winning I did see
Rook A5 but I did not realize that uh it
was uh pinned um I as soon as I at first
when I saw like Queen B7 I'm first
thinking okay like Bishop G 3 Rook takes
G3 like sacrifices to force the draw and
then I'm I have this AR wait I can take
the knife like I can win this game
because you you know you would never
assume that the king is so safe but
after King
H6 and him having no time in the clock
it seems very difficult but apparently
there was a draw after Rook A5 according
to one of your the person who brought me
over here right and A5 actually was a
key Square in the game because there was
another line that Christian Christian
showed us here where it was actually
losing for you but a crazy move for for
Sam right do you remember Christian I'm
trying to remember so Rook A5 was
winning no no no Rook Rook A5 is a draw
but sooner The Rook C8 and A5 oh so this
was yes yes yes I know what you're
talking about at that point Rook to
D1 it was a good decision but only in my
estimation if you see this move Rook to
C8 did you spot this idea with Rook to
of course I saw Rook C8 Rook takes G3
now King F1 and next move is A5 trapping
more or less trapping the queen
yeah this I saw um I had some some I
thought Rook takes B3 was holding but I
guess not Rook takes B3 Queen takes F7
and H H5 I didn't see H5 this was the
key move yeah I missed I missed H5 and
it's an easy move to miss and the
problem is if you do go E5 I can just
simply take your Rook that's the oh wow
yeah that's yeah that's even more
ridiculous wow yeah yeah and even if you
put the Rook on
I will still take it Queen takes F5 oh
wow yeah that's yeah that's that's quite
something and the problem is you do take
my Rook at the end but you also get
checkmated no oh yeah that's oh that's
painful H congratulations uh big victory
for you go recover after this crazy game
and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you thank you Hans and
inde congratulations on an amazing gift